do you think social media is about
connecting or narcissism were both and
his narcissism a bad thing well you know
Andrew a keen he just sort of book
called digital vertigo which is great he
goes that this whole thing is all
narcissism and but he talks about being
an author you need social if you're an
author or filmmaker like you know your
films don't exist unless people see them
your books you can't survive on less
people buy your books how are you going
to do that unless you have some big
corporation behind you which most
filmmakers and authors don't you have to
let people know what you're working on
so I hate that it's like the word nars
you know if you're an independent
filmmaker you must let people know what
you're doing it's required a film
doesn't live unless someone's watching
it so I think you could you could say
it's a little bit of both but you could
also say it's a way to make a living
it's a way to share your work and my
work right now is so collaborative the
film's don't even exist unless people
send us their you know their
contributions for these cloud films so I
don't know I I'm my husband and I had
just been making up a new word which is
a skeptic mist which is a combination of
optimist and sky like I'm an optimistic
I'm a rational optimist or if you call
it optus ISM what we decided skepta mysm
sounded better but I in in essence look
at the world in a positive way I
ultimately believe in humanity I believe
people are good I believe you know we
have a lot of things pulling us but
ultimately good will win we've had a lot
of opportunities to blow ourselves up as
a society as a world and we haven't we
in essence want a better world for our
children I think we're ultimately good
and there's you know there's not some
great stuff that comes along the way but
ultimately I believe in humanity
I think dr. Drew's talked about
narcissism is being more prevalent noun
in the age of social media do you think
it's a requirement for most artists you
were saying that most people don't have
the money to pay for someone to promote
them so isn't almost well maybe that's
going back to the business question
because you know if you want to support
yourself as an artist people need to
know what you're doing and they need to
be able to support you so you have to
have a look at this but to me I would
call that a business sense you know you
can say oh that's narcissistic if you're
promoting your stuff but if you're a
business person you're like no one's
going to buy in my film connected unless
I let the notes for sale I mean is it to
me it's a little bit I just don't I
don't think of it that way because I
think of it as a business situation and
I also think of it as a community
situation like I'm people are psyched
you know we have a new film coming out
our last film we release it and people
shared it all over and it was so much
fun I mean it's like we're offering
something out to the world that we made
with people from all over the world so
it to me it's a generous act and it's
not a and then my films where I need to
make money from it I would love my
investors to get their money back so
they invest in more documentaries so you
know that's important
you